moi je suis dans le village alors c'est
très sympa c'est des immeubles
tranquille toujours des trucs à faire on
est aux gones il ya quand même le cadre
de la campagne mais aussi l'agitation de
la ville le côté nature résidentiel
avec beaucoup d espaces verts ale les
ennemis montain aiment leur commune
qu'ils soient habitants commerçants
ce qui explique peut-être la 219e place
au classement de l'association villes et
villages ça nous conforte par rapport
aux choix politiques qui sont menées
depuis très longtemps anodine puisque on
voit que ceux ci sont régulièrement en
avant si on sur nos choix en aménagement
des différents quartiers
le fait d'avoir des bâtiments à taille
humaine avoir de la mixité fonctionnelle
ceci à chaque année quartier d'avoir une
grande place aux espaces verts de faire
aussi de gros efforts en matière de
sécurité et quatre communes saint
quentinois sont présentes dans ce
classement
trapé la première avec le sens 91e rang
25 believe rhinois sont distingués la
première versailles se classent 49e
on n'a pas le lac d'annecy on n'a pas
les montagnes à côté c'est vrai le
château n'a un parc extraordinaire c'est
déjà un atout je pense que ce qui jouer
pour nous c'était la qualité de
l'enseignement qui très connus ainsi
personnes je pense aussi que c'est une
ville relativement sûre santé éducation
ou encore solidarité 183 critères ont
permis de classer les trente quatre
mille communes françaises
les loges en josas ont cette année à la
9e place dans le palmarès des villes de
moins de 2000 habitants